what does it say to the world when
maverick is scared of the chinese
communists
and i would point out unfortunately
the chinese
censorship is being carried out by
hollywood billionaires who are getting
richer in the process
in recent days it's been reported that
one of joe biden's top
potential choices to be ambassador to
china
is the former ceo of disney
who happens to be a major democratic
donor
disney just came out with the movie
mulan in the movie mulan
which the director described as quote a
love letter to china
well this love letter wasn't subtle
because right in the credits at the end
of mulan
they thank the oppressive government
forces who are
running concentration camps right now
with over one million uyghurs imprisoned
disney gleefully thanked the jack-booted
thugs that are carrying out torture and
murder
and apparently the leader of that effort
is one of the top candidates to be
america's ambassador to china
well the senator from illinois the
senator from connecticut said we need to
stand with people who are oppressed
i agree look hollywood could say
whatever they want
but there's no reason the federal
government should facilitate their
censorship on behalf of the chinese
communists and the script act simply
says if you're going to let the chinese
communists censor
your movies you're not going to get
access to the
jet planes into the ships and all the
different materiel of the federal
government that is used in movies
moments ago the senator from connecticut
said they want to be tough
on china well we're about to see how
tough they are on china
i will happily yield for a question can
you tell me if you were successful
and if you hit hollywood hard how that
provides
any solace to the 6 700 chinese and hong
kong students in america
who are facing the deportation back to
prison
in china senator from illinois asked a
question let me tell you how it provides
solace
because people who are in hell holes
they listen to what we're saying
people who are in hell holes they hear
the voice you know some time ago
i had the chance to sit down with anton
sharansky
the famed soviet dissident he and i sat
down and visited in jerusalem
and atan told me about how when he was
in a soviet gulag
that in the cells from cell to cell they
would pass
notes did you hear what ronald reagan
said
the soviet union is an evil empire
marxism leninism will end up on the ash
heap of history
mr gorbachev tear down
this wall
and i'll tell you how people here
because of the center from illinois will
remember i
introduced legislation to rename the
street in front of the chinese embassy
in in the united states lujan bao plaza
after lujan the nobel peace laureate
who was let me finish answering your
question if you want to propound a
second one i'm happy to answer that one
too liu jiabao was the nobel peace
laureate
wrongfully imprisoned in china
and the strategy of renaming the street
in front of the embassy is a strategy
reagan employed
renaming the street in front of the
soviet embassy sakura plaza
twice i stood on this floor seeking
unanimous consent
and twice a democrat the senior senator
from california stood up and objected
and at one point the senior senator from
california said well if we do this
it will embarrass the chinese government
to which i responded
you are understanding correctly and
that's not a
bug it's a feature that is the purpose
and let me tell you what happened to
that
twice democrats objected to the
legislation
i then placed a hold on president
obama's nominees to the state department
and the obama administration came to me
and said how can we move
these nominees forward how can we move
them forward i said it's very simple
pass my legislation and i'll lift the
hold the democratic caucus didn't like
that
but they ultimately agreed and so the
legislation i
i introduced to rename the street in
front of the chinese embassy lujaba
plaza
passed this body unanimously
now ultimately the house didn't take it
up and pass it up but i'll tell you how
that story ends that story ends
in 2017 when i was sitting down with rex
tillerson for breakfast at foggy bottom
the new u.s secretary of state and when
he spoke
to his chinese counterparts he said they
have come back and said among their top
three diplomatic objectives with us
is stop your bill to rename the street
in front of the embassy they are
terrified
by the sunlight and sunshine on the
dissidents
at the time lingerie had passed
but his widow liu xiao was still in
china still
wrongfully held back and i told
secretary of state tillerson i said i'll
tell you what
you tell the chinese if they release
luxia
if they let her get out
i'll stop pressing this particular bill
and if they don't i'll keep pressing it
and we'll pass it again
because we've already done it within
weeks china released lucha
so you ask how does this help the people
in prison by not
having hollywood media moguls
spreading chinese propaganda but let me
give you a second choice
very directly you want to know how
people are helped a second bill
called the shame act which
if our democratic colleagues want to be
tough in china we could pass right now
what does the shame act do
the shame act focuses in particular on
human rights atrocities
it focuses on over a million uyghurs in
concentration camps and other religious
minorities and the falun gong
practitioners who are captured
and murdered and whose organs are
harvested
and the chinese communist party engages
in yet another horror
my democratic colleagues like to say on
the question of abortion they are
pro-choice
well the chinese communist government
right now is engaging in
forced sterilizations and forced
abortions
taking uighur mothers and forcing them
to abort their children against their
wills
whatever the democrats views on abortion
in the united states is a matter of a
woman's
surely they must be united in saying a
government forcing a woman to abort her
child to take the life of her unborn
child
is an unspeakable atrocity
so the shame act does something very
simple it imposes
sanctions on the chinese communist
government leaders responsible
for implementing this horrific 1984
style policy
of forced sterilizations and forced
abortions
now i intended to seek unanimous consent
for the shame act as well
but my democratic colleagues have said
they're not yet able to find a democrat
to object although my understanding is
they intend to
i hope they reconsider that a terrific
ending for today's debate would be
passing the shame act and saying
we're all standing together against
forced abortions and grotesque
human rights violations maybe that will
happen maybe it won't
but let's find out where we are on the
question
of the script act
senator from connecticut reserving the
right to object
i think we've gone a little bit far
afield from
the oh that's it okay six pro-democracy
activists
living abroad uh
from connecticut i did not yet yield to
the floor and about to ask the unanimous
consent so
the senator from texas mr president
as if in legislative session i ask
unanimous consent that the committee on
homeland security and governmental
affairs be discharged from further
consideration
of s 3835 and the senate proceed to its
immediate consideration
further that this bill be considered
read a third time and passed
and that the motion to reconsider be
considered made and laid upon the table
with no intervening action or debate is
there objection
mr president senator from connecticut
thank you mr president
uh reserving the right to object on the
scripps act which i understand
is the only measure so far on which
the senator from texas is seeking
unanimous consent
very simply he knows i know
we all know that measure will never
reach
the president's desk there's simply no
way it can pass both houses of congress
in the next few days before the end of
this
congress the only way we can do
something for the
freedom fighters and democracy advocates
in communist china is to pass
this measure that he has objected
to which has unanimously passed
the house of representatives only hr
8428 offers that opportunity and frankly
only this measure that he's objected to
does anything for the dissidents
or the democracy advocates or the
freedom fighters
he's talking about movies we're talking
about
human lives he can draw all the kind of
hypothetical connections between
the so-called movie moguls in hollywood
and china but i think
his scripps act actually
works against the goal that he is
advocating
censorship in china is a
legitimate concern no question about it
and i
would welcome the opportunity to work
with him on a bill that does something
about it but actually
his bill not only takes away the support
for
the movies that may be made it takes
away
support from documentaries about the
repressive
regime in china it takes away
classification and other security
screening that is necessary for those
kinds of movies
to be shown in this country i think that
kind of
obstacle may be inadvertent on his part
but i welcome the chance to work with
him on a bipartisan bill
a truly bipartisan bill that in fact in
the next congress
could reach the president's death this
one
that he's offering the scripps act goes
nowhere but i just want to bring us back
to the reality
that really is an issue here
just last wednesday afternoon of this
week two of the activists
among the six pro-democracy
fighters living abroad charged under
china's new national security law were
before
our committee i'm wondering what they
are thinking
when they hear my colleague from texas
pounding the table about
being tough on china but objecting to a
bill
that guarantees them
protection as i say
i'm talking about their lives and
tens of thousands of others
i'm not talking about movies i'm not
talking about
hollywood moguls let's stand up for the
lives
of those chinese hong kong freedom
fighters
now in this country seeking protection
through a bill
passed unanimously by the house of
representatives
the only bill that will go to the
president's desk
if we approve it thank you
is there objection
the objection was heard mr president
senator from texas
three brief observations number one the
senator from connecticut said
multiple times that the house bill in
question passed the house unanimously
i am sure this is inadvertent but what
the senator from connecticut said is
simply wrong
it passed the house by voice vote which
is a very different thing from passing
unanimously it simply means the vote
tally was not recorded
secondly the senator from connecticut
said the script act
is not going to pass this congress
that appears to be correct but that is
for one reason and one reason only
which is the final two words uttered by
the senator from connecticut
i object quite
literally by doing nothing quite
literally by giving the identical speech
he had just given
and then closing his mouth before those
final two words
had that occurred the script act would
have passed this body unanimously
so the only reason the script act isn't
passing is because the senate democrats
are objecting
and it should not be lost on anybody
that the hollywood billionaires
who are enriching themselves with this
chinese propaganda
are among the biggest political donors
to today's democratic party in the
entire country
senator from connecticut said well the
script act
might make it possible to have
documentaries
on the human rights abuse abuses in
china
oh really
that argument
staggers the mind it it so
defies reality because you know what
hollywood doesn't make movies
about the human rights abuses in china
earlier this year i had the opportunity
to meet richard gere
now richard gere is not someone you
would ordinarily imagine
palling around with a conservative
republican from texas but richard gere
was up here
he was up here actually
standing up against chinese abuses
and urging anyone who would listen
republican or democrat to stand with him
you know richard gere has not made a
single major hollywood movie in a decade
why because he dared stand with tibet
and the hollywood billionaires
blackballed richard gere if you speak
out for tibet if you do what the senator
from connecticut just suggested
and discuss the chinese human rights
abuses it doesn't matter
that richard gere used to be an a-list
hollywood blockbuster actor
boom his career is dead because no
studio will produce a movie with him
because he spooks spoke the truth
and by the way my bill presents zero
barriers to someone actually making a
documentary
on the human rights abuses in china
because presumably if you're making that
documentary
you wouldn't allow the chinese communist
government
to censor it i don't know what kind of
documentaries the senator from
connecticut is familiar with but i'm not
familiar
fun on tyrants and concentration camps
where you let the concentration camp
guards
edit out the stuff they don't like
that ain't a documentary
senator from connecticut said perhaps we
can work together in a bipartisan manner
to address this i hope so
standing together against the oppression
of the chinese communists would be a
very good thing for the united states
senate to be a very good thing for our
country
unfortunately at least today
that hasn't yet happened i yield the
floor
the senator from connecticut mr
president the only
ones happy with the outcome of today's
debate
are the chinese government
and i regret
this outcome because
there probably was a time when we would
have
cooperated in a bipartisan way
on both of these measures
and it may not have been unanimous there
may have been a few
contrary votes in the house but clearly
it came here with bipartisan support and
i regret
that the outcome today is not bipartisan
agreement
to protect those freedom fighters who
came before the judiciary committee
and who have risked their lives this
issue
is not going away we'll be back
because fortunately
the activists from hong kong will
persist
in their fight
and we ought to do everything we can to
make sure they have a safe haven
in this country and that they are
protected here
so my closing plea to my colleague from
texas
is that maybe there remains time
even in this session but if not
we need to take a stand as a nation
against chinese censorship against
repression by the chinese and come
together and work together thank you mr
chairman
mr president senator from florida first
i'd like to do is comment on the uh
discussions we just had you know i've
been up here a little less than two
years and thing that surprises me is
invariably the democrats won't stand up
against the communist party of china
uh the case that we're dealing with now
is you know they don't want us
you know they're going to stand up for
hollywood
continued fight uh for rights
uh for all the rights that we have in
this country but fighting for those
rights so people in
whether in hong kong or in communist
china or in taiwan
have the same freedoms that we have so i
want to thank senator ted cruz for
showing up today and doing this
today what i'm going to talk about is
religious freedom religious liberty is
our first
freedom under the constitution of the
united states americans have the right
to
freely exercise religion a sacred right
that i'll always fight for
there is no pandemic exception to the
first amendment
unfortunately we've seen liberal
governors and mayors across the country
use the chronovirus pandemic
to go after churches synagogues
mosque and other houses of worship for
months they've argued that houses of
worship should not meet in congress
congregants could not sing
they've condemned in-person worship
services as a threat to public safety
all while they've applauded massive
political protest
we saw it happen right here in the
nation's capital mayor bowser refused to
grant a waiver to the capitol hill
baptist church
for religious gatherings but supported
mass protests that violated her own
orders
the church had to sue this city in
federal court for the right to gather
and the court ruled in favor of the
church
it's simply hypocritical and
unconstitutional to target religious
institutions
while letting other businesses operate
we know those on the left will take
every opportunity to infringe on
americans first amendment rights
but we won't let it happen this year has
been
challenging and for many of us our faith
and our community have helped us through
it government doesn't have a right to
take away the take this away from
american citizens
i'm proud to lead a resolution today
with 15 of my colleagues
to call out those who have wrongly tried
to prevent americans
from practicing their faith this is
about rights
granted to americans under our
constitution
what's the one thing every american
believes in
and has agreed to uphold is our
constitution which we have
each sworn uphold as elected officials
also
we each took the same oath of office
i do solemnly swear that i will support
and defend the constitution of the
united states against
all enemies foreign and domestic that i
will bear truth faith and allegiance
to the same take this away one should
objective
object to upholding our constitution i
will always fight for the religious
liberty of all americans
and i look forward to my colleagues
passing this important resolution today
however i now am going to wait because i
understand one of my democratic
colleagues is going to come object
to upholding the constitution and the
first amendment
the bill of rights it's just shocking to
me
do
do
senator from florida as if in
legislative session i ask unanimous
consent the center proceed to the
consideration of center resolution 806
submitted earlier today further i ask
unanimous consent that resolution be
agreed to
the preamble be agreed to and that the
motions to reconsider be considered made
and laid upon the table with no
intervening action or debate
is there objection mr president the
senator from new jersey
mr president reserving the right to
object
my colleague senator scott
has chosen an interesting point in this
pandemic
to object to public safety measures
intended to protect human life
and ensure scarce resources are not
squandered
over 17 million americans
17 million have contracted
copen that we know of
and over 300 000
of our friends and our neighbors
and loved ones are no longer with us
think about that september 11th was a
great national tragedy
i know because i lost 700 of those 3 000
citizens on that fateful day from new
jersey
this is a hundred times more than what
happened on september 11th
people we have lost are not just some
nameless numbers
but mothers and fathers and grandparents
essential parts of our hearts are gone
forever due to the pandemic
that has been mishandled and mismanaged
from the start
and now when this virus is running
unchecked to our communities
we have before us this resolution that
is riddled
with misstatements of fact that i find
deeply
concerning no governor wants to see
their constituents cut off
from their daily lives and i think we
can
all agree that the
administration here in washington their
inability to guide us through this
crisis
has left our governors holding the bag
when it comes to securing resources
providing guidance and making the
difficult calls about the right public
policy
to prevent covet 19 from ram rampaging
like an unchecked bull in a china shop
through our states
because they know that the governors of
our states that the lives of their
residents our neighbors brothers
sisters children and parents rest in
their hands
and these difficult decisions they must
make
we are still losing americans from covet
19
at an unprecedented rate hospitals
throughout the country are providing
an amazing level of care with exhausted
providers
and continued resource issues and our
economy is cratering
because we cannot fully reopen it until
it is safe
now i'm deeply troubled to see a false
claim
about my state and the governor banning
indoor religious services let me be
clear
houses of worship were never ordered
closed
never in fact today religious gatherings
are allowed to have substantially higher
capacity limits
than most other gatherings while new
jersey restricted the capacity of indoor
religious services
as they did with all indoor
gatherings religious gatherings were
never
never designated as non-essential
or essential as this resolution suggests
that distinction was only applied
to retail businesses now perhaps
religion is different in florida
but our houses of worship are not retail
businesses
houses of worship and religious
organizations have been subject to
neutral restrictions that equally burden
religious
and non-religious entities they were put
in place to do what
to save lives not under the guise of
doing so
and certainly not for the purpose of
targeting religious groups
now i am a man of strong faith and
conviction
i have always found deep soulless in the
rituals and shared worship of my church
i know many of us have but perhaps the
most important part of my faith is the
duty
the responsibility to care for my
neighbors up and down the state of new
jersey and all across the nation
our faith calls us to ensure the health
and safety of this nation before
all else as a matter of fact i'm
reminded of a passage in the bible from
james 2 14.
it says what good is it my brothers and
sisters
if you say you have faith but do not
have works
can faith save you if a brother or
sister is naked and lacks daily food and
one of you says to them
go in peace keep warm and get your fill
and yet you do not supply their bodily
needs what is the good of that
so faith by itself it has no works is
dead
but someone will say you have faith and
i have works
show me your faith apart from your works
and i by my works will show you
my faith as for me
i'll continue to work for the people of
new jersey our health care workers
struggling to care for the thousands
filling icu hospital beds for the
families who don't know
how they will pay next month's rent and
keep food on the table
for the small business owner trying to
keep his doors open
and yes for churches who want to see
their parishioners safe
i however do not intend to play these
partisan games and for those reasons i
object
the objection is heard mr president
senator from florida
freedom of religion shouldn't be
controversial this is a fundamental
right of our nation as stated in our
constitution
congress shall make no law respecting
the establishment of religion or
prohibiting the free exercise thereof
what this resolution does it says it
affirms
its support the senate affirms its
support for the rights
liberties protections enshrined in the
united states constitution
there is no there is no pandemic
exception to the first amendment
for months across this country liberal
politicians have targeted churches
synagogues mosque and other houses of
worship
to let this happen undermines the
principle of our nation
and the constitution will have each
sworn to uphold his elected officials
i don't understand why my colleague who
swore to uphold the constitution
would object to a resolution that simply
reaffirms
our commitment to upholding the
constitution
we are blessed to live in a great nation
that respects religious liberty and the
right to worship
especially as we see countries around
the world like communist china and iran
deny their citizens these same rights
americans have the right to worship and
government doesn't get to decide for
them
i'm clearly very disappointed my
colleague doesn't want to protect the
first amendment
which i will continue to stand against
these misguided and hypocritical
attempts to target religious
institutions
i'm never going to stop fighting for the
religious liberty of all americans
even during a pandemic thank you and i
yield the floor
senator from new jersey
i know that my colleague i understand is
going to be the next chair the
senator republican senatorial campaign
committee
and he has every right to do that
but what he has no right to do
is misrepresent in this resolution
what at least in my state is going on
you cannot say that churches were
designated by the state of new jersey as
non-essential or essential that's simply
not true
it's simply not true you cannot
suggest that somehow
these purposes are to target religions
they have to save lives now maybe if
my colleague and others here had spoken
up when the administration was asleep at
the switch
as this pandemic was raging
maybe if my colleagues had spoken up
when we found out that the president
knew back
in january or early february of this
year of how
vicious this pandemic could be
how contagious it could be how it was
transmitted
but said nothing to the american people
and that silence was echoed
in this chamber well
maybe then we wouldn't be in the
position that we are in
maybe we wouldn't have lost 300
000 of our fellow americans
so i i find it
really really upsetting that in the
midst of a raging pandemic
one would seek to obtain political
value out of something that is just
simply not the case simply
not the case i think there's a lot more
to be done in this chamber
to stop this pandemic to stop more lives
from being lost
to save our brothers and sisters
to help those who have been ravaged by
the pandemic
but not to pick a few
states that happen to be democratic
please
senator from florida so if my colleague
from new jersey's concern
is paragraph number four on page three
i would i would ask him if he would uh
object if we just take that paragraph
out and then he would be willing to
affirm uh that the senate believes in
religious freedom
the the resolution is senator from new
jersey the resolution is replete
with inaccuracies and therefore i will
continue to object
so let's mr from florida so let's
remember the concern was that
he didn't like the section about new
jersey
and so that was inaccurate but the idea
that we're going to support the senate
will
support religious freedom he is not
willing to stand behind
thank you i yield the floor
um
um oh
foreign
so
so
uh
foreign
oh
foreign
this
mr president i would ask suspension of
the quorum call
the senate senate is not in a quorum
call
thank you mr president the senator for
michigan thank you
mr president we truly don't have any
time to waste
the american people are in desperate
need of help
and i want to start by thanking all of
my colleagues
who've been working so hard together
across the aisle to bring us
to a point where we can actually provide
some help albeit temporary
to the american people so
thank you and i'm pleased to have been
involved in
elements of that negotiation and
appreciate it
but we're stuck right now and i just
want to remind
people of a few numbers
more than one in three american adults
in a recent survey said they're
struggling to pay
household expenses including rent and
mortgage
we don't get something done
in the next hours or days
we are going to see thousands of people
in michigan
lose their homes in the middle of the
winter
7.8 million americans have fallen into
poverty since
june 7.8 million people
have fallen into poverty since june
the number of people applying for
unemployment keeps rising
885 000 people filed
initial claims last week
and thousands and thousands and
thousands of people who are
self-employed
who are contract workers others
will find themselves with zero support
right after christmas unless we take
action a recent survey found that
one in four small businesses are in
danger of
closing if the economic conditions don't
improve
one out of four talked to
so many friends so many people in
michigan vibrant small businesses they
put it all on the line
for that business they always wanted to
have
and now they're barely holding on and
they need help and they needed help
before
now they need help now they are waiting
and waiting
and waiting and holding their breath
up to 50 million americans are
struggling to feed their families right
now
one out of four american households have
experienced
food and security in this last year so
one out of four households
people who volunteer at the food bank
people who have always contributed to
the food bank
now find themselves waiting in their car
for hours and hours for a box of food
in the united states of america
we not only have a health pandemic we
have a hunger crisis
going on and people need help now
and on top of that this past wednesday
306
3 638 americans died
in one day of coronavirus
and we're now looking at government
services shutting down
in less than 12 hours the backdrop of
everything that is happening for
americans
and despite all the good work that's
been going on
in a bipartisan basis we're now within
less than 12 hours of services
for people into our country shutting
down
and why
because my colleague the republican
senator from pennsylvania thinks it's
more important to take away the federal
government's ability
to help people and help businesses and
create jobs
than it is to actually help people now i
want to say
senator toomey and i had a wonderful
hearing this week in our health
subcommittee and finance of which he
chairs and we have been working
together doing really important
meaningful things
on alzheimer's disease and i have very
much enjoyed
doing that but on this
issue on this issue at this time
with so many people in pain and so much
hardship
at this moment i don't understand
when he said that preventing the next
treasury secretary in the federal
reserve from relaunching
the emergency credit facilities that
support manufacturers and other job
providers
is quote the most important thing
in this clovid19 package really
really the most important thing in this
package is to take away the tools of the
treasury
and the federal reserve that have been
used
when we're in crisis and we need to be a
backstop for our businesses
in the credit market when we need to be
supporting
job providers and jobs really
really that is the most important thing
tell that to a mom who's afraid your
kids will end up on the street because
she can't pay her
rent in january which is
like two weeks away
tell that to the small business owner
who's having to lay off their entire
staff
a week before christmas
tell that to a senior citizen who's
risking his health
by waiting in an hour's long line to get
a box of food
tell that to the health care workers who
are literally putting their lives
on the line right now fighting this
pandemic
really taking away economic tools
for the treasury and the fed
are more important than people
in our country small businesses
farmers who've been hanging on
really
tell that to the thousands of american
families who are preparing for their
first holiday
without loved ones who have been lost to
the virus
just yesterday another
loss in michigan so many losses
thousands of losses but a
a dear friend a sheriff of wayne county
benny napoleon and his family
today a funeral for
a friend as well in detroit
so the most important thing is not
supporting families it's not helping
people at least get through the winter
at least get through the next several
months to put food on the table and the
roof over their heads and
help their businesses and and make sure
the vaccines can be distributed and
support our health care workers and
put money into education and all the
other things that are needed right now
the most
important thing
is have a fight with the treasury and
the fed because you'll want to limit
what they can do
in terms of their powers to help people
and to help businesses in a crisis
our nation is in a crisis
and we'd be in an even deeper crisis
right now if it weren't for the federal
reserve
the federal reserve stepped in early
during the crisis
under the current administration i might
add where nobody was suggesting
that we provide these kinds of
amendments or
restrictions then on the current
administration
and the trump administration i didn't
hear that debate maybe i
missed him but i didn't hear that debate
but thank goodness we didn't have the
debate because they stepped in early
taking extraordinary measures to keep
credit from freezing
up for our businesses
this is the money that businesses use to
provide services and keep
people employed and i have to say as
someone
coming from a major manufacturing state
like pennsylvania
like ohio like indiana
like wisconsin
that having the capacity for the fed to
step in and provide
some confidence in the marketplace
so that our auto suppliers our other
manufacturers could
get what they needed in terms of
liquidity
was critical to jobs
thousands and thousands and thousands
and thousands of jobs
the emergency powers that the federal
reserve has
were put in place during the 2008
financial crisis
so that the fed could respond quickly to
the next crisis
well here we are in the next
crisis the crisis is
all around us and yet some
are laser focused on taking away the
fed's ability to respond
in the future with a new president
not the current such president but
future present this is like a fire
department selling off its fire trucks
while houses down the street are burning
2020 has been brutal
emblems
and then the logo you can
a long time
[Music]
get in the car
i'm out yeah all the time